quand j'entends le bruit
en arrivant sur le tarmac quand
j'entends cette hélice qui commence à
tourner mon coeur s'accélère mes mains
glissent je n'ai plus de salive
j'ai juste envie de partir au courant et
pourtant c'est plus fort que moi je sais
qu'une fois de plus je vais monter dans
cet avion
cet avion c'est un pilatus pour faire de
la chute libre à ce moment là j'ai 27
ans et je suis en nouvelle zélande
tous les jours si les conditions sont
bonnes je monte dans cet avion pour
sauter en parachute et à chaque fois je
me dis que je suis folle que je risque
ma vie que ce n'est pas pour moi et je
monte dans l'avion
il suffit juste que je lève mon pied que
je le pose à l'intérieur de l'avion et
que je grimpe dedans c'est le pas le
plus difficile parce qu'ensuite tout
s'enchaîne la règle si tu montes tu
sautes on ne peut pas redescendre avec
l'avion le parachute pourrait se
déclencher automatiquement dans la
carlingue
vous imaginez la scène dix minutes a
grimpé en tournant dans le ciel et à me
demander mais qu'est ce que je fais là
assise par terre dans tout ce vacarme
avec en plus cette odeur de kérosène et
heureusement à chaque fois gino un
brésilien super beau me décroche un
énorme sourire et attila un endroit avec
des dreadlocks lève son pouce en l'air
pour moi ces encouragements me donne la
force de me lever au moment où la porte
s'ouvre sur le vide là la technique
préférée pour sauter c'est me tenir un
morceau de la halle de l'avion de mettre
un pied sur la route et l'autre en l'air
comme ça comme belmondo
chacun ses références mais moi avoir cet
exemple-là en tête
ça m'a franchement aidé et je suis monté
dans cet avion
43 x 43 sauce et rien dans le monde de
la chute libre mais pour moi c'est
énorme je ne suis pas une tête brûlée et
en plus
j'ai le vertige alors pourquoi j'ai fait
ce choix
pourquoi je suis monté dans cet avion
parce qu'à 14 ans déjà l'idée de faire
du parachute me faisait vibrer parce que
je sentais que c'était pour moi que
c'était juste pour moi que je devais
vivre cette expérience
alors quand l'occasion s'est présentée
quand l'avion est passé devant moi à 27
ans je suis monté dedans et ça c'est mon
sourire à l'arrivée de mon premier saut
je me sens libre heureuse d'avoir subi
mon intuition
je me sens surtout profondément vivante
à cette période de ma vie je suis
journaliste
j'ai su que je serais journalistes le
jour où dans mon collège de campagne un
grand reporter est venu nous présenter
son métier je ressens alors les mêmes
vibrations cas l'idée de sauter en
parachute le journalisme c'est pour moi
en fac je croise un prof qui croient en
moi
ces cinq minutes de conversation c'est
comme le sourire de tignes où pour la
première fois je me sens légitime pour
devenir journaliste jose appelé les
rédactions
j'enchaîne les stages je découvre le
monde magique de la radio je fais une
école de journalisme et grâce à la
productrice emmanuelle bastide
j'entre en stage dans ce qui était pour
moi le rêve rfi rfi c'est radio france
internationale un fabuleux sésame pour
mieux comprendre le monde et surtout
voyagé dans ma chambre d'enfant je
passais des heures à rêver de ce rocher
rouge un désir absolu d'australie
quelques années plus tard mais de rêve
se réalise en même temps pour ma
première mission en tant que journaliste
pour rfi
j'ai été envoyé en australie comme si
depuis toujours au fond de moi je savais
ce qui était juste pour moi peut-être
que vos si vous ressentez cette
sensation de justesse cette intuition
qui vous fait dire que ce chemin est le
vôtre qu'il n'est pas
au moins bien qu'un autre mais qu'il est
le vôtre et que si l'avion passe à ce
moment là il vous faut absolument monter
dedans pendant sept ans de tarmac en
termes ac je visite le monde
je voyage dans une quarantaine de pays
en inde en mongolie en la hausse alors
au libye dans plein d'autres pays
passionnant avec tous mes sens en éveil
j'apprends à me faire confiance et avoir
confiance en la vie j'essaie du mieux
possible de comprendre le monde à
travers ma spécialité l'éducation je
découvre notamment les pédagogies
alternatives qui permettent à chaque
enfant d'avancé à son propre rythme
comme par exemple la pédagogie
montessori et en même temps je rencontre
le futur père de mes enfants je vois
vous vous posez une question donc je
vais y répondre
non ce n'était pas jean au camp notre
premier enfant arrive à l'âge de trois
ans nous habitons en bretagne je cherche
donc pour ma fille une école alternative
montessori dans le morbihan je cherche
dans tout le département
il n'y en a pas alors avec manuela
radenne une autre maman on décide de la
créer cette école manuel albite
larmor-baden petit village où l'école
privée à fermer une école magnifique aux
normes avec même du parquet par terre
tout proche de la mer la première fois
que je rencontre manuela devant cette
école je me remets à vivre entièrement
c'est pour nous c'est pour moi il faut
absolument que je monte dans cet avion
nous mettons des affiches partout à 20
km à la ronde
nouvelle école montessori ouverture en
septembre
portes ouvertes ce week-end trois jours
plus tard le samedi à 14 heures l'école
est noire de monde et le dimanche soir
nous avons trouvé les enseignants à
l'école et complète pour deux ans avec
manuela nous étions montés dans l'avion
et là on n'avait plus le choix on ne
pouvait plus redescendre parce que des
enfants et des familles compter sur nous
alors nous nous sommes lancés
aujourd'hui quatre ans plus tard l'école
les mimosas accueille près de 60 enfants
et emploie neuf personnes dont cinq à
temps plein avec les avec l'école
j'apprends la puissance de l'entr'aide
tellement de parents se sont retroussé
les manches
chacun chacune apporté sa compétence un
idéal commun améliorer l'école pour nos
enfants avec l'école j'apprends le
pouvoir des valeurs positives l'espoir
la confiance à quel point notre énergie
notre enthousiasme peuvent soulever des
montagnes
l'année dernière par exemple les parents
entièrement construit de nouvelles
classes tout un bâtiment au moment de la
création de l'école je suis enceinte de
notre deuxième enfant
monfils net en juillet et deux mois
après l'école ouvre ses portes en
septembre il était encore bébé quand
brutalement je me retrouve seule
procédure de divorce
banal banal sauf que d'un coup ma vie
bascule même si dans mes moments de
lucidité j'essaie de voir cela comme une
expérience sociologique intéressante
la situation est si dur moralement
physiquement matériellement que j'ai
parfois envie que tout s'arrête
mon meilleur ami crise qui est
réalisateur de documentaires et
aventuriers décident de m'appeler tous
les jours où qu'ils se trouvent en
sibérie ou chez les papes
il m'appelle tous les jours pendant des
mois c'est ma bouée il me répète d'avoir
confiance en la vie il me dit que j'ai
toutes les ressources en moins et qu'il
sait que je suis capable de recréer une
autre forme de bonheur un jour je lui
demande s'il n'en a pas marre de menton
de pleurer il me répond ah non mais je
me demande quand tout ce que je te dis
va enfin rentrer dans ton cerveau et la
j'éclate de rire
il a raison j'ai le choix soit je reste
dans la peau d'une pseudo victime et je
ne vais pas aller bien loin
soit j'accepte ce qui est là comme une
nouvelle donne je ne peux rien changer à
la situation de toute façon je peux
juste accepter je ne suis pas victime
cette relation dans l'avons construite à
2 je suis actrice de ma vie responsable
de ma vie comment à partir de ce qui est
pour moi un énorme déséquilibre
je vais réussir à construire un nouvel
équilibre forcément différent mais dans
lequel je vais pouvoir y mettre à
nouveau de la joie et de l'harmonie même
si l'école est présente dans ma vie et
jusqu'à ce jour la page est blanche
immaculée
du coup je n'ai plus rien à perdre et
tout à construire
je suis convaincu aujourd'hui que si on
reste juste et droit
fidèle à ses valeurs en suivant son
intuition on ne peut pas se tromper que
parfois les épreuves qui se trouvent sur
notre chemin aussi douloureuses ou
inacceptable soit elle en ou
déséquilibrant nous permettent de faire
ressortir le meilleur de nous mêmes
peut-être qu'elles nous permettront de
jouer un rôle différent dans la société
de prendre une place différente
d'apporter une vision différente
je suis une nouvelle fois devant le vide
je choisi de reprendre en main les rênes
de ma vie de parent et stella de sauter
à nouveau ma priorité est de trouver un
travail
si possible un travail qui me rend
heureuse utile à la société
compatible avec mon nouveau statut de
maman solo tout en restant dans mon
petit village parce que forcément il ya
l'école et la mer franchement réunir
toutes ces conditions c'est pas gagné je
me dis que la seule solution c'est de le
créer ce travail on avait bien créer une
école et là je sens les listes de
l'avion qui se remettent à vrombir pour
moi pour décoller je vais devoir me
délester de la plupart de mes peurs je
venais de regarder certaines bien en
face je suis toujours vivante
alors à quoi bon laisser celle qu'ils
restent eux bloqués je m'accroche au
positif et je me prépare à un nouveau
saut à rfi pendant quelques mois j'ai eu
la chance de présenter une émission sur
les droits des femmes dans le monde je
parlais surtout d excision des viols
comme arme de guerre et des assassinats
politiques
je réalise à quel point les inégalités
existent en france aussi sous d'autres
formes
je découvre la précarité des mamans sous
l'eau je lis j'observe un jour je me
rends un concours de startups organisée
par des amis là je ne voit quasiment pas
de femmes le soir autour d'une bonne
bouteille de vin rouge avec mes amis je
leur demande mais pourquoi il a si peu
de femmes
pourquoi elle ne se lance pas dans les
startups comme vous ils me répondent
c'est simple nous les hommes quand on a
30 % une idée on lève la main et on y va
et vous les femmes il vous faut souvent
60 70 voire 100% d'une idée avant d'oser
vous lancer je me dis ok maintenant je
vais agir comme eux
je sais que je vais aider les femmes à
croire en elle et en leur projet ça doit
déjà bien faire dans les 10 % de l'idée
qu'est ce qui freine autant les femmes
le manque de confiance
le manque d' exemple et le manque de
réseau j'aimais 30%
mon idée un réseau social bienveillant
pour aider les porteuses de projets à
croire en elle a créé leur entreprise
un réseau qui mettrait en lien toutes
les femmes qui souhaitent centre est d
apporter leurs compétences
un réseau pour mettre en lumière les
porteuses de projets les chefs
d'entreprise pour qu'elles puissent
devenir des sources d'inspiration et de
motivation
un réseau pour les encourager à créer
les entreprises de demain innovantes
verte et solidaire
c'est fou comme à partir du moment où on
croit profondément en quelque chose des
coups de pouce inespéré semble surgir de
nulle part
grâce au soutien d'un grand groupe de
partenaires privés et publics d'hommes
et de femmes que je remercie infiniment
je me retrouve d'un coup dans un avion
supersonique le réseau social femme de
bretagne né fin septembre 2014
neuf mois plus tard nous sommes 1700
membres dans toute la bretagne
imaginez le potentiel de 1700 femmes qui
ont envie de s'entraider pour mieux se
réaliser alors certes un homme me disent
oui mais les filles à rester entre vous
vous allez vous enfermez c'est quand
même pas très bon vous voyez la
différence entre les dîners entre
couples les dîners entre guin et les
dîners entre filles c'est le même état
d'esprit la même convivialité la même
complicité
sauf que c'est à l'échelle de la
bretagne professionnel est centré sur
l'entrepreneuriat oui mais nous les
hommes aussi on a des peurs des freins
des blocages ça j'en doute pas
homme de bretagne est née le 1er avril
2015 ce qui n'était au départ qu'un
poisson d'avril orchestrée par quelques
hommes est aujourd'hui devenu un soutien
sur twitter alors pour qu'il prenne de
l'ampleur
à vous de jouer les hommes on a besoin
de vous et on vous a vu ce qui m'aide à
garder le cap dans toutes ces
turbulences et ses tours et ses trous
d'air c'est un petit bout d'homme et un
petit bout de femme mes enfants pour eux
comme pour la plupart des enfants tout
est encore effectivement du domaine du
possible
et cette confiance en eux en la vie en
les autres j'ai envie qu'il la garde
j'ai envie qu'ils puissent reconnaître
leur chemin
quels qu'ils soient est monté dans leur
propre avion
j'ai envie qu au moment de sauter il se
fasse confiance et qu'il trouvera les
ressources en eau pour oser oser aller
de l'avant osez recommencer malgré les
chutes les échelles au des nausées
donner le meilleur d'eux même osé
choisir ce qui est le mieux pour eux je
pense que dès qu'ils en auront là je
leur offrirai des cours de pilotage
aujourd'hui je trouve que la vie est
facétieuse je me demande ce qu'elle va
bien encore me réserve et je n'en ai
aucune idée
juste la certitude que les expériences
difficiles ou positives seront comme des
panneaux indicateurs pour m'aider à
avancer sur mon propre chemin et il
trouver de nouveaux avions
après quand je grimpe de dans ma vie
n'est pas plus facile mais c'est celle
que j'ai choisie
alors quand on m'a proposé de participer
à ce talent x j ai à nouveau les mains
moites la gorge sèche le coeur à mille à
l'heure je me suis dit à nouveau que ce
n'était pas pour moi et que j'étais
folle et puis le bruit de l'hélice a été
le plus fort alors me voilà je suis en
pleine chute libre en plein saut devant
vous et grâce à vous une nouvelle fois
je me sens profondément vivante
merci